hey guys I'm Ryan right oh hey guys I'm
Celina Myers we just watched a video
called vomit cake and I feel awesome
we're gonna check out Assassin's Creed
syndicate meets parkour in real life in
4k syndicate takes place in London I
believe so let's see parkour
that
cool
nice
nice
yes emergency
Wow
I not have balls
Wow
one chance given
wait
so [ __ ] impressive
smart
hmm that's like legitimately inspiring
me because you know I want to make like
films I want to make short films on I
want to transfer in a feature this is so
[ __ ] cool like I hope I know there's
an assassin's Creed movie coming out I
hope they do like parkour and they
really do include yeah kind of stuff
because that look [ __ ] off and they
should be the stars they should be the
star they're so [ __ ] brave yeah like
so dangerous like everything like with
one little you know mistake they could
they could really die the craziest [ __ ]
is when like it's always super
impressive when they jump from like one
building to another building or like
you're just a little thing to jump on
when they like flip onto another morning
that is [ __ ] nuts and it takes so
much body strength to do anything like
that like I know these guys are probably
so good at [ __ ]
you know what I mean they're probably
really good at sex
imagine having sex with them Jelena
parkour sex they're just having sex
flipping through the city yeah well
anyway guys thanks for singing that
without that was really well worth it if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out Selena's channel you can
check out Selena's channel color my
energy and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and she has a snapchat
I have a vine and periscope because if
we get enough followers on any of these
we can get product placement for things
such as ear phones ear phones are great
you know like if you're listening to
your music watching a movie on your
laptop or if like your girlfriend's in
the other room you know practicing
guitar or something you could be on
pornhub calm jerking off the headphones
on she won't even know what's going on
because she can't hear it she ain't here
you jerking it you know the same thing
if you're a girl and if your guys in the
other room you know if you're DJing
yourself I'm telling you guys earphones
and they can get you to a place you want
to be yet that was the best
advertisement for headphones ever
I know